so this week Vladimir Putin um in a
speech said to his Russian
people that um all Russia must now
prepare for Total War even if you are
not
fighting uh on the front lines in
Ukraine pretend you
are and uh because of the speech there
are many analysts who believe that Putin
is preparing Russia for Total War and
Total War means that every aspect of
your of your Society is geared towards
winning a war and so we had La we last
had total war in World War II okay uh
but not after that so why is Putin doing
this now um there are some people who
believe that it's
because Russia is not doing so well in
Ukraine they lack Manpower and and so
they need to mobilize their society to
fully win the war in
Ukraine okay another explanation is that
PL uh Putin knows that NATO is preparing
to send reinforcements to Ukraine
remember that because of um last
Summer's offensive Ukraine is
desperately short of Manpower okay the
average age of their soldiers right now
is over 40 they have men in their 60s
who are fighting in the front
lines um emanu macron of France um have
has publicly stated that he is
considering sending French troops to
Ukraine uh the British themselves are
thinking of conscription drafting all
young men into the army the Americans uh
American politicians have said that
they're considering a new law that would
give CIP to illegal immigrants who join
the Army okay so it seems like NATO um
is only going to escalate the war in
Ukraine and so Russia is preparing for
that one more explanation one more
possibility is that Putin wants to
expand the war okay so he knows he's
winning in Ukraine and he's thinking
about U attacking Mo
mova uh and possibly uh the Baltic
states okay these are all
possibilities today this morning what I
want to do is argue another possibility
which is
that
Putin is mobilizing his Society because
he sees War as a tool as a mechanism to
radically
reshape the people in
Russia so think of a metaphor okay
you're fat and you're like okay how do I
get fit how do I get trim right you go
to the gym and you
out and for Putin that's what war is war
is a workout for your for for your
society when you enter War you become a
much more
disciplined unified and prosperous
Society okay so that's what I want to
argue today okay so why does Putin think
like this well let's look at the current
state
of Russia okay Russia in many aspects is
a broken Society
corruption Russia is the most corrupt
Society in all of
Europe uh the rich people steal and then
they run off to Europe or the United
States or
Dubai okay so corruption is a huge
problem in uh Russia and because of
corruption um the GDP of Russia is very
low so South Korea which has about a
third of the population of Russia has a
higher GDP okay the state of Texas just
one state in the United States has a
higher GDP than Russia so Russia in many
uh respects is a very poor country okay
second problem
is
alcoholism one out of every six Russian
males about 16 17% of the population
uh they're they're alcoholics
okay it's a disease they they have the
disease of
alcoholism one of every three deaths in
Russia is because of drinking too
much and because of alcoholism the um
the rate of young men dying is just
increasing and increasing
Okay the third problem is fertility
so right now the fertility rate in
Russia is 1.5 that is below the
replacement level right remember that
the replacement level for society is
2.1 Russia is 1.5 the problem is you
have you have a lot of men dying because
of alcoholism okay so since the year
2000 the population in Russia has been
declining
steadily and all this means is that if
current trends continue Contin then
Russia will cease to exist as as a
society okay the nation will die so why
is this happening well okay the Wern
explanation is that this is happening
because Russia is not
Democratic right if you had full
democracy and you unleash the human
potential of your
people then Russia will
Prosper but Putin vladim Putin has a
different
explanation okay his explanation is that
this is happening to Russia okay
corruption alcoholism and low
fertility because Russians have been
lied to
deceived and manipulated by Western
Civilization Western Civilization
preaches the gospel of liberal democracy
of freedom of human rights of
consumerism and these are all lies
they're hypocrisies that have fooled the
Russian
people and have corrupted the Russian
soul and destroyed Russian
civilization and because Russians are
abandoning their soul their civilization
their Nation this is
why this is happening right does that
make sense that is Putin's argument so
why does Putin believe this well um in
the late 80s the Soviet Union had
basically lost the Cold War and they
lost the Cold War because their Elite
basically gave up they no longer believe
in communism they didn't believe in s
self-sacrifice for the nation uh they
felt that Western values the Western uh
lifestyle was much better okay so they
gave up um in the late 80s
there was an American historian he
actually he actually works for the
American state department but his name
is Francis
fukuyama and he wrote an extremely
influential essay called the end of
History end of History okay uh with a
quotation
mark and he argued
that the Soviet Union fell and America
became triumphant because liberal
democracy
is the best idea to have ever been
invented and to make his argument he
uses uh the philosopher federick Hegel
okay now federick Hegel had something
called the theory of the dialectic
dialectic and what Hegel argued is that
history is determined by a war of
ideas the progress of history is
determined by the movement of
ideas and how ideas work is that they
have a pattern called the dialectic okay
so there's a
thesis a new idea comes into
being but then we recognize that this
idea has problems it's too extreme it's
too problematic so we create an
antithesis
okay but this antithesis itself is also
to extreme and this creates also
problems so then what happens is the
thesis and the anesis come together and
create a more moderate more efficient
idea okay called the
symphysis and this is
how history moves or progresses and so
fukayama takes this idea and says okay
well this explains what's happening
today where at first you have a thesis
called capitalism
okay capitalism and this create the
Industrial Revolution right and because
capitalism was too extreme we move
towards communism okay communism was
created to counteract the extremes of
capitalism but communism itself is to
extreme so then we move towards the
which is the right idea which is called
liberal
democracy okay so what is liberal
democracy well at the core of liberal
democracy is the idea of
consumerism and the idea of consumerism
is that we
exist to buy things and as long as we
buy things there'll be World Peace why
because consumers have a need to buy and
therefore Nations have a need to produce
and Nations produce the best when
they're trading together as opposed to
Waring against each
other okay so this is the argument that
Francis fuk fukuyama makes um in the end
of History
I want to explain this argument further
okay what's what's he really saying okay
so um throughout human history all
societies have struggled with one
problem which is how do we
optimize the workforce how do we get
each and every person to work as hard as
possible for our
society and if everyone did that then
our society would be strong United and
prosperous right okay so a fundamental
problem of politics how do you optimize
uh Workforce participation okay and
traditionally or historically there have
been three answers the first is
war the second is
religion and the third is civilization
okay now um as you can understand these
three things work because they give
structure
meaning and
purpose to our lives okay and we have
structure meaning and purpose we are
much more motivated to work hard but as
you can also see there are actually lots
of
problems with all three right war is you
kill people that's bad uh religion is
superstitious okay
but civilization itself is also
problematic because the logical extreme
of
civilization is racism
okay which is to say that we Russians
are better than everyone else we Chinese
are better than everyone else therefore
we can do whatever we want okay and this
naturally leads to
imperialism
right we have a duty to go conquer other
people to civilize them right something
call The White Man's
Burden and this leads to Fascism
okay okay war and Conquest are the
ultimate good so historically War
religion and civilization have given
people structure meaning and purpose but
they create a lot of problems they
create suffering and War and pain okay
so but over time what has happened is
that um all of them over time have
become much more
abstract and the reason why um theyve
become more abstract is in order to
increase the population in order to um
create Mass Society okay so let me give
you an example of this the earliest
religions uh in humanity have been
polytheistic okay and the gods
themselves were very much like humans so
think of the Greeks okay
Zeus um Athena Hera okay was a
polytheistic
society and they were very much like
humans but over
time this polytheism became monotheistic
it became abstract okay the idea of God
was so much removed from us and the
benefit of that is that you can you can
have more people believing in one
God and it it motivate you to work
harder okay because it's such an
abstract
concept and because of
abstraction um we develop new ideas for
example money
okay so rather than have War religion
and
civilization as the structure and Center
our society want to make money the
structure of your Society okay and this
this what we call
capitalism and capitalism of course led
to the Industrial Revolution
industrialism okay capitalism meant that
societies uh were becoming welfare and
Welfare more industrial and more IND
more industrialized okay does that make
sense all
right but there's a problem with
capitalism right what's a problem with
making capital or money at the very
heart of your
Society exactly okay so the first major
problem of capitalism is it's all
consuming so so as Jack says all
capitalism cares about is the expansion
and growth of capital Capital regardless
of its effect on society okay profit for
the sake of growing profit it's an all
consuming idea which can ultimately lead
to the destruction of the planet okay
that's the first problem what's another
problem with capitalism or or the idea
of having money as the heart and center
of your
Society anyone
okay um so what's H what this means is
that money likes to consolidate itself
okay consolidating okay meaning that if
so the example is let's just say that
each of us had a million dollars right
what's the fastest way for us to grow
our
money if we put it together right and
then we can go invest
it okay so in other words
if you just let capitalism do whatever
it wants to Infinity what happens is
that you you exactly have one person
with all the money okay does that make
sense because that's the fastest way to
grow money by consolidating it okay so
that's problematic what else is wrong
with capitalism or
money okay so another problem is the
idea of
alienating or dehumanizing
okay what does this
mean capital alienates and
dehumanizes what does that
mean exactly okay you are you as a
person cease to be human right to be a
human is to be a complex
multifaceted
individual who likes to to create and
love but in capitalism you're only your
production value you're only the amount
of money in your bank account okay does
that make sense all right so for all
these reasons capitalism is really bad
there are actually more reasons okay um
so Carl
Marx and his Communist Manifesto points
out all these problems of capitalism and
he proposes a solution which is okay
rather than make money at the heart and
center of your industrial society make
the
worker the heart and center of your
Society okay so he makes his argument
but what's very revolutionary or presant
about his argument is this is a natural
cycle okay this is part of the Hegel
cycle where capitalism com along and
communism will be the Natural
Evolution of capitalism okay
why okay okay so let's do the thought
experiment okay let's do this thought
experiment where your parents have died
and now you're working in a factory in
order to survive how do you feel about
this your parents have died there's no
one to support you so at age 16 17 18
you have to go off to a factory to make
money for yourself so how do you feel
about
this are you happy about
this H how how do you
feel depressing
and and lonely
and yeah exactly okay you're bitter and
you're depressed okay okay you're
alienated so then what do you
do then what do you
do what can you do
now you're bitter you're angry you're
depressed you're lonely so what do you
do okay you start to think about why
this is the case right you start to have
a a political Consciousness okay what
Mark calls political
Consciousness from this alienation of
the worker workers will start to develop
a political Consciousness right they're
like why is this happening why has the
government abandoned me why has Society
abandoned me what can I do about this
okay so then what
happens that's exactly right you want
change right and how and how how do you
enact
change yes okay you spread your ideas
and you organize right and when you
organize what do you
realize yeah you what you recognize when
you when you start to organize is the
capitalist need you to do the work right
the capitalist own the capital and the
factories but you're the one who's
actually doing the real work so without
without you the factories can't run so
as long as you say
United you can enact whatever political
demands you want okay does that make
sense okay so for Marx this is just a
natural evolution of capitalism
capitalism leads to the alienation of
the working class which will lead to
their political Consciousness which will
lead to their solidarity which will lead
to a political revolution and so you can
make the worker as the heart and center
of your
Society
okay doesn't make sense guys all
right now what's amazing about marks is
that today we say he's wrong right
communism happened in the Soviet Union
it happened in China but it happened in
Europe and in United States where Marx
said it would happen first because
Germany was more industrialized than
Russia or China okay does that make
sense that's that's that's what we say
if you think about it
deeply
okay um Marx is
right after World War II every society
every industrial society to some extent
adopted the ideas of
Communism does that make sense okay we
call the Socialist is M and not
communism but basically it adhere to the
thinking of Marx which is to make the
worker the heart and center of your
society and and why do they do that
after World War
II exactly okay because workers create
value okay money doesn't create any
value money just creates more money it's
okay it's speculative but the workers
create value they're productive and
therefore you have to treat your workers
properly so in America and in Europe
workers became the heart and center of
your society and the workers through
unions could uh demand political reforms
and so our society was geared towards
making the lives of the middle class the
working class better okay that's why you
had excellent Healthcare great great
Public
Schools um cheap
universities okay so the 50s and 60s and
70s was basically the
peak uh of society for the working
class but in the
80s we start to change this
why why would why would we want to
change the system it's a great system
right Marx is right having the worker as
the heart and center of your of your
society as the Central organizing unit
of of society makes a lot more sense
than having money as the Harden Center
okay but start in the 80s we start to go
back to money
why excuse me
who wants
more yes exactly okay so what happened
in the 80s is something called the
Revolt of the
elite okay in other words the problem
with having a society based on the
worker is it becomes too egalitarian too
equal right but if you're like the elite
you don't want equality you want
difference you want to have power and
money in your hands does that make sense
so the Revol of elite happened in the
80s and this is what we call in United
States the re Reagan Revolution okay the
Reagan
Revolution the beginning of NE
liberalism free market capitalism and in
Britain it was called thatcherism okay
Mar thater the thater
Revolution and so now you need to
transition away from the worker to
something else okay another ideology
that allows the elite to a mass power
okay so just to show you how radical
this Revolution was in the 1970s okay
1970s if you were a CEO the head of a
company okay you were making on average
$1 million us a year that's pretty good
right that's really good
money and that $1 million was more than
20 times
the
worker
okay and
that's pretty
reasonable today the average CEO in
United States makes $20 million a year
and that is 200 to 300 times more than
the average worker in the company okay
does that make sense
so um in the 80s inequality start to
explode right and so they're
transitioning from the worker to a new
organizing unit called the
consumer okay so they needed to destroy
the the working class the middle class
and the way they did it was by
introducing a new concept called the
consumer okay so in the 50s 60s and 70s
the government promised you a good job
if you were a member of a society if you
citizen I promise you a good
job that you would have for the rest of
your life okay so in the 80s the
government said I promise you that you
have low prices and a wide selection of
goods okay does that make
sense all right so this sounds like a
subtle shift going from the worker to
the consumer okay but what this meant
was a
revolution in society a revolution in
politics so remember that an example the
worker the worker has to have political
Consciousness in order to protect his or
her rights in order to organize and and
unify and uh push for favorable
political reforms okay that's what what
the worker must do okay but now let's
think about the mentality of the
consumer and to do this let's do another
thought exper experiment and the thought
experiment experiment is this everyone
in the school about 500
people I decide to give
everyone1 million us okay so everyone in
the school has exactly 1 million US
dollar to
spend what happens
now think about this what happens now
use your
imagination What Happens what's the
first thing you
do what's the first thing you
do I've given you a million dollars what
do you do with
it well the first thing you do is buy
something right what do you want to
buy a $1 million is a lot of money what
what what do you want to buy na
you buy a house right that's great
that's a great purchase then what do you
do with then what do you
do okay first thing is not buys a house
then then what does he
do excuse me buy furniture then what
does he do and there's something that he
must do that's very important what what
what's he by the house what does he want
to do
he wants to take pictures and post on
social media right so everyone sees on
social media
then you see this now has this huge
house in Beijing with lots of fancy
furniture what do you do
now you also want to buy a house but
what kind of
house a bigger house right and then what
do you
do you also post pictures okay then how
do other people
feel you you think this is funny okay
but this happens all the time so very
quickly what happens in the
school and you yeah you all spend your
money and you all go into debt right
because you're in competition with each
other to buy the biggest thing and $1
million is a lot of money but it's not
enough
to buy everything right so you go into
debt you borrow more more money to buy
more things and then what
happens and then what
happens how do you guys feel about each
other do you guys have lunch together do
you guys have dinner together do you
guys like like to share homework
together you guys hate each other right
at the end of the day what will happen
is you all go to debt and you all hate
each other right so that's consumerism
this is what what consumerism is
consumerism creates a
competition in society for Prestige okay
to see who can POS the nicest social
media pictures this leads to the
individualization or the
optimization of you okay in other words
you are now
unable to act together you don't want to
organize you don't want to act in
solidarity okay and ultimately this
means
that you develop economic logic okay and
what is economic logic it's to see the
world only through the lands of
capital okay does that make sense
so when you when you see someone and you
you like okay well do I want to date
this person you don't ask oh is this
person a nice person you you ask
yourself how much money does this person
have okay do you understand you use
economic logic in order to understand
the world and to reason and analyze the
world okay now let me ask you this
question today is this how China Works
is is how the world works
the answer is yes okay are do you are
you like
this yes you are like this okay you've
been brainwashed into thinking thinking
that this is the only way to behave and
to think you in school why are you in
school so you're get a good job
why to make money and so you can buy
things okay you understand that's how
you all think but there are different
ways to think about school right you're
like I'm in school to learn to open my
mind to have an imagination to think
critically about the world right and
that was the way we thought about school
when the workers were dominant but now
that consumers are dominant all we think
about is how do I get a good job how do
I buy a bigger house because I want to
post it on social
media
okay so if you think about this what
this really is is the
Perfection of
slavery okay does it make
sense what does this phrase mean the
Perfection of
slavery yeah he becomes a slave of the
money but but but what why is this
perfect yes okay do you understand if
you're a slave you be beheld right right
but you don't know your slave and you
like this you choose this then you will
never Rebel Okay so the consumerism is
the
Perfection of
slavery okay and that's why fris
fukuyama thinks that consumerism is the
end of History because it is a
system that achieves what the elites
want and the masses
are unwilling and unable to protest and
rebel okay does that make sense it's a
perfect
system okay
so but there are certain
civilizations that rebel against
slavery intrinsically it is in their
nature to rebel against slavery and one
of the civilizations is the Russian
civilization okay so when you impose
slav
on
Russians they become corrupt they become
alcoholics and they refuse to have
babies that is why Russia is failing as
a society because slavery is being
imposed on Russians by Western by the
westerners and the Russians refuse to be
slaves but because the system of
consumerism is so perfect Russian people
lack a understanding of how to rebel
against the system and that's why Russia
is falling apart
okay that is a Putin argument does that
make
sense okay in other words consumerism
has corrupted the Russian
soul and Russians have chosen to be
corrupted by
consumerism okay so doesn't make sense
so what Vladimir Putin must do is free
his people
even though they may enjoy prison okay
even though Russians may enjoy slavery
Putin is still going to free his people
and he's going to do it by creating a
New Concept to combat consumerism Okay
so we've gone from the worker to the
consumer and Putin is going to introduce
A New Concept called The
Warrior the consumer is a person
an individual who acts
alone and does so to
preserve his or her life okay the
consumer is a coward the consumer lacks
imagination the consumer is alienated
the warrior is different the warrior is
an individual who sees that through his
actions he or she can shape the
direction of
History I I can make my own reality
through my courage and through my
imagination and by acting with others
okay does that make sense all right
so let's do another thought experiment
to understand the warrior concept let's
just say that okay in the school I give
everyone a million dollars and now you
hate each other okay then what happens
is I put you on a plane and I take you
all to an island okay and you're on this
island and unfortunately on this island
there are millions and millions of flesh
eating monkeys they want to eat
you okay but you hate each other you
don't want to work together what happens
now what happens
now yeah that's right if you don't do
anything everyone gets eaten by a monkey
right but what are you going to
do how you will F the monkeys by how
will you f the
monkeys okay what's GNA happen is that
everyone is going to put
aside the differences and work together
to fight the monkeys
okay and how you feel in this
process are you going be happy or
depressed
you're gonna be happy
why exactly you're all working towards
the same goal okay structure meaning and
purpose okay that's what war does war
gives you structure meaning and purpose
so you feel happy about yourself okay
let just say that during this
war um like Seline dies okay now what
happens
what does death do
now
yeah
yes
and so Seline dies she want a martyr you
all celebrate her remember her you give
her great funeral and then what do you
do you fight harder do you understand
because the death gives you purpose her
death makes your life much more valuable
to you and to your others okay not only
do you celebrate her life but you
celebrate her your own life okay all
right now let's just say that the
monkeys are coming okay and there's a
bridge there's a bridge and Jack is
standing on this bridge and there are 10
of you on the other side okay so Jack
has a choice he can either cut the
bridge and kill himself and save the
others or he can run R run and possibly
all get killed right by the monkeys what
what does Jack
do for sure he will do this what will he
do he's going to sacrifice himself okay
do you understand we've seen this in war
over and over okay that's what war does
to people it makes you it gives you
structure meaning and purpose and it
makes you a stronger more disciplined
person
okay does that make
sense right so that's the thought
experiment so in theory then when uh
Putin launched this military operation
it's it's called a special military
operation in Ukraine back in February
2022 then we should see improvements in
Russian Society okay does that make
sense so um what's happened in Russia
since this war are people happier
do you think people are
happier you think people are happier
now okay I think they are you think
people are more
unified I think they are okay so one
example of this
is the Russian
economy is surviving us sanctions in
fact it's getting stronger and stronger
why because people are fully
participating in the economy now okay so
an example of this is that every
month Russia is producing
150,000 ammunition cells okay for the
war every month Russia is producing more
ammunition cells shells for the war okay
150,000 can you guys guess how much how
every how much United States produ every
month in comparison
guess guess the
number ex
me 100
100,000 2,000
okay you understand so Russia is gearing
towards a a war economy it's factories
are producing more and more weapons but
that means more and more people are
employed
which means that they're drinking less
okay when you have structure and meaning
and purpose in in your Society all this
goes down okay corruption goes down
alcoholism goes down oh sorry fertility
goes up all right does that make
sense so um last
year Putin made the statement okay he
was asked okay you have a lot of
Russians dying on the battlefield and he
said well when they die on the
battlefield we honor
them they sacrificed themselves for
their country they'll always be
remembered as Heroes their families will
always love them but if we just let them
do whatever they want all they're going
to do is drink themselves to
death okay you understand so I put in a
saying is that what war is ultimately it
is a mechanism for society to rejuvenate
itself okay what war is it's opportunity
for society to cut away the fat to make
itself more
lean so for Putin this war is not really
about conquering Ukraine or defending
against NATO it's really about saving
Russian civilization it's really about
saving the Russian
Soul okay you don't if you don't fight
this war and you let these Trends
continue then Russia will eventually
cease to exist as a
nation does that make
sense okay so what's going to happen is
that over time A New Concept will arise
to challenge consumerism and liberal
democracy and we will call this concept
putinism and and the idea of putinism is
really continuous
war that as a society you should be
constantly funding Wars in order to
discipline
unify your
nation okay and make your
people stronger and more prosperous that
is putinism okay and that and and I
think this will be his defining
Legacy and pism is a direct response to
Liberal democracy okay so we will shift
as a society from one that is based on
the consumer to one that is based on the
warrior does that make sense
guys okay any
questions oh um so Selen asked a
question
how is capitalism different from Liberal
democracy that's a great question okay
so um capitalism is only concerned about
capital okay so you can be a fascist
country and be
capitalistic so capitalism many people
will say leads to Fascism so Nazis were
extremely capitalistic they see
communism the Soviet Union as direct
threat to its existence okay the idea of
a liberal democracy is the participation
of everyone in the generation of
capital does make sense so in other
words um and this this is this is one of
the ironies of the 20th century is that
capitalism and democracy are opposing
forces and the idea of liberal democracy
is to put the two together in a
symphasis as to explain a
way or ignore the contradictions okay
but capitalism and democracy are
contradictions does that make sense okay
any more
questions okay so Jack makes a great
point which is like Wars have been
fought
before um have destroyed societies okay
think so think of Athens and Sparta um
and think of World War II and War one
okay societies become exhausted and
destroyed so the idea of continuous war
is you fight small scale Wars so as to
manage the size of the conflict okay and
it's important to do that why why don't
you want a large scale
war no no no no you what what might
happen in a large scale War
that's that's right okay the problem is
you have nuclear weapons in place now
okay so it is
not it's not smart to fight a large
scale War because you fight a large
scale War you can't really
control um the escalation and eventually
say United States and Russia fight a
ground war in Europe eventually they'll
be so angry at each other they might
have to use nuclear weapons okay that's
why uh one of the major tenants of
putinism is you pick small contained
conflicts so Ukraine is a small
contained conflict okay an invasion of
France or or invasion of Britain would
lead to nuclear war does that make sense
okay and that's why the United States
would also pick Iran because Iran would
be a small contained conflict does that
make sense okay so so this is the
putinism okay war is a mechanism to
transform your Society whereas before we
understood War as a mechanism to conquer
others okay as imperialism or the
spreading of Civilization now the IDE
pism is no guys we don't care about the
other people we care about ourselves
we're using War as basically a mechanism
to discipline our bodies just like the
gym okay does that make sense okay the
thing about global leaders world leaders
is they're all insane but they're not
stupid you understand there's a
difference
they're happy to kill millions of people
they're not happy to blow up the
world
okay but uh Jack's other point is that
Russia is not a very wealthy country
right eventually you're going to exhaust
yourself and um that's why we think war
is usually a pyramid
scheme okay what that means is um so so
the EXA the example is Nazi Germany when
they were fighing these wars and it was
costing their economy a lot of money so
they were forced to fight even more Wars
okay that's what eventually led to
Germany's invasion of Russia because
they needed the resources and the
Manpower okay and that's the same thing
that will happen here where okay Putin
is spending a lot of money to fight this
one
Ukraine okay but after after he finishes
war in Ukraine then need he needs to go
con more territory for their
resources okay so in the long
term uh this could lead to disaster okay
this could lead to a large scale War but
in the short term um it does work okay
does that make sense okay any more
questions okay so SEL asked a great
question which is like eventually people
are going to get
exhausted okay and what
Putin um believes is that the Russians
are a warrior
culture okay Russians enjoy War Russians
are good at War
so Russians won't be exhausted by the by
War they'll be galvanized and energized
by War that's a theory okay and he's
right okay there are Warrior cultures
out there around the world that do enjoy
fighting okay so you think of the German
people right the Germans have been
fighting Wars for thousand years and
they've been really good at it okay you
think of Japanese okay J Japan is also a
warrior culture that enjoys fighting
Wars okay China is not a warrior culture
it's very hard to get Chinese to fight
Wars and Chinese okay so I hate I hate
to say but China would probably lose
most wars okay it's not a word culture
so for Chinese civilization War would be
exhausting but for Russian civilization
War can be um energizing and
rejuvenating okay does that make sense
it depends on on your
civilization okay any more questions
okay so
um what's going to happen and the answer
is that um Warrior culture works right
now okay because word culture beats
consumer culture easily so you see the
one Ukraine where Russians are
destroying the ukrainians and the
Europeans are like ah I'm too busy
watching TV I'm I'm too busy
uh buying things I'm do busy vacation
okay so consumers don't want to go to
war okay but eventually Russia is going
to reach a point where it directly
threatens Germany and France and Britain
and then they will start to transition
into a War culture okay so
putinism will become the dominant
ideology for the next 50 years okay but
putinism can spread to other countries
okay so Japan can adopt putinism Germany
can adopt it Britain can adopt it okay
and so the world we call so when this
happens we call this world
multipolar so the word we use is
multipolar okay or multipolarity meaning
that like there are different centers of
power throughout the world right now
there's only United States it's a global
hedgemon but over the next 10 20 years
we expect a multipolar world where each
region has different
hamon okay does that make
sense all right any more
questions okay so um what happens to
United States so next week we'll discuss
United States okay but what I will show
you is that if United States fights this
war in Iran what it has to do is Retreat
back to its borders okay it has to
become isolationist but I I'll explain
that to you that I'll explain that to
you next week okay any more
questions sorry sorry go
ahead
and
asiv connected
so I think like can I interpret pism as
another form
oftion of
slavery a bigger scale slavery okay so
that's a great question okay so we just
said that consumer culture is the
Perfection of slavery but it's word
culture
slavery and you can make the argument
that it's actually anti-slavery
why why
what can the warrior do that that the
consumer cannot
do what's the problem what's the problem
with having a War culture
really ex
me no what can Warriors do that that
consumers would never
do guys Warriors can
Rebel right Warriors can Mutiny the AR
can be like you guys are terrible we're
going to rebel against you okay you
understand does that make sense to you
you cons don't do that consum like hm
I'm going to Rebel I'm I'm I'm going to
stop buying things no one's going to do
that okay you'll never be like I'm gonna
stop buying things because I think it's
bad for the environment you won't do
that whereas Warriors like you know what
I don't like this leader let's march to
Moscow and get rid of him they can do
that and they they they they do that all
the time that's why War culture is so
destructive and that's why War culture
was so dominant before and then we got
rid of it because for political leaders
where culture is a direct threat does
that make sense okay so but in this
question uh this reviews a contradiction
in putinism okay what is the ultimate
problem in Putin turning his entire
country into a wor wor Society what's
the problem with
that and it's a huge problem for Russia
and this is why uh ultimately Russia
will not Triumph in a multi-polar world
in fact it'll probably this it'll
probably fall apart
why for a world culture to Triumph what
does it
need Warriors fight best when When
what when there's a king guys when
there's a king that's why we have
Kings right so what's what's problem
with Putin's
Russia what's going to happen to
Russia guys eventually Putin is goingon
to die you understand eventually he's
going to die and then what's going to
happen the country is going to fall
apart because it's a warrior culture and
you have these different generals
fighting each other for total control
it's going to be civil war okay Putin
right now is a strategic genius he's the
king everyone admires him so he unites
everyone he can direct all Society into
Total War when he dies this Society is
going to fall apart okay that's why
Putin's Legacy will not be a strong
Russia it'll be putinism okay the idea
of continuous War Russia may not um
survive about Putin
okay and hon quite honestly when you
have a great leader like Putin it's
impossible to replace
him all right no one no one would have
his genius and authority and
ruthlessness okay does that make sense
okay all right and David you have a
question okay so David asked a great
question okay how much of society agrees
with Putin and the answer is
like no one most people don't like to go
to war okay most people are scared by
War but ultimately Society is determined
by those who are willing to act on their
beliefs okay so when we looked at
America look they issue a
Lobby um they're only a small
faction small fraction of the American
population like less than 1% okay but
because you're willing to act and
they're organized and they're determined
they get their way does that make sense
same same thing in Russia where at most
okay I would say at most you have 10%
who are like oh putinism is a great idea
let's go conquer the world okay at most
you have 10% most people are like we
want peace we want to live our
lives we I have children I want to I
want my children to be safe I don't want
to send my children to war okay but
again history is determined by those
those who are determined to act in
unison okay so it's usually the most
extreme uh individuals who get their way
does that make sense okay but but thanks
for the question okay any more
questions um okay so Putin believes that
Russia is first foremost a great
civilization okay but as a great
civilization it also has to fight Wars
to protect
itself you understand so Putin's like
you know what if America left us alone
we would not fight Wars okay it's only
because America insists on encircling us
insist on trying to destroy our culture
our civilization that we must fight a
war
okay does that make sense right and so
what what what people say is listen the
war in Ukraine it's ultimately caused by
NATO uh encroachment into Russia right
so NATO uh after the Soviet Union fell
expanded five times guys NATO was set up
as a defensive defensive alliance
against Soviet Union well if you don't
have a Soviet Union you don't need NATO
anymore so why is NATO expanding in fact
NATO was was going to expand into
Ukraine so Putin is like we are fighting
this war ultimately to defend our
civilization that's what matters the
defense of of our civilization and if it
requires us into going if it requires us
to go to war then we will do
so okay and it's is this process that
will create putinism okay or continuous
War does that make
sense okay any more questions
yeah okay
so even though only 10% agree with
putinism I actually don't know the real
number okay but I think it's only a
minority what happens is that
um in war people become much more
unified okay so the example is Ukraine
where actually about 50% of the people
in Ukraine were Russian speakers okay
and there was a large group of people at
least a third who are sympathetic
towards Russia but the moment that uh
Putin invaded they all United under
zalinsky okay so that's what war does
War unifies people so again back to the
um Island example you guys may hate each
other when you land on the island but
hey if there's a million flesh eating
monkeys that want to kill you you guys
are going to become a family okay does
that make
sense okay any more
questions is this clear to you guys
okay you you you you you you look as so
you you want to ask a question
you confused by something
Seline excuse
me okay um so again Russia is a warrior
culture it enjoys War it's good at
fighting Wars okay but China is not a
warrior
culture and the reason why is that
throughout most of Chinese history China
was the dominant power the hamon okay
also China is surrounded by natural
defenses right so to the uh East you
have the
sea to the South and to the West you
have mountains to the north you have the
Great Wall okay so China doesn't feel
threatened by anyone and therefore it
doesn't have a Weare culture does that
make sense but Russia is a huge country
that's been invaded multiple times and
all these invasions were traumatic for
Russia okay so you look at the German
invasion of the Soviet Union in 1941
that killed 20 million people millions
of Russians died in that war and people
still celebrate that war okay so um
China is not aware
culture right does that make
sense okay any more questions
okay so what we will do uh next week is
we'll talk about Putin's strategic
genius okay and what I what I will show
you um and this be interesting is that
the way that Russians see the world is
radically different from the way we see
the world okay so so so we'll discuss uh
Putin's
strategy moving forward next class okay
does that make sense all right good